Dave dama Shack from the NFL Network
love me some Dave damn [ __ ] good see
check ace what a pleasure to see you
I've been listening since you kick
things off at 6 a.m. local time gang
bust your stuff with you and the fellas
yeah it's quite a sort of magical what
about really knowing you tell me about
Fritzi I'm a little unclear on well
Michael Evans one of the yeah you know
in terms of just initial chemistry never
had anything better May allure female by
the way as far 7-eleven gun goes Seaton
obviously the same thing I got over
there Polly it's just a he's
johnny-on-the-spot and he does you know
I think the key detail of the frit sees
Fritzi is don't sleep on the inflection
of the voice that's right Polly it's
interesting he and I have kibbutz on
social media over the past year or so
and and I just had an awkward meeting
the most awkward of all places to meet
anybody in the toilet III his back he
turned around to me and and and I
introduced myself to him and immediately
regretted doing you know that's not the
right what's policy there we both
recognize each other should I go head
down make sure to wash the hands so it
doesn't get out that I didn't yeah or do
I say hey how you doing elbows
fortunately you didn't wash your hands
no that wasn't an issue thank you I'm uh
there's a couple things by the way you
missed this little pearl I was in the
bathroom earlier this morning saw chant
walk past me barefoot oh no oh yes oh
yes oh yes he was barefoot and then he
walked past me like you're barefoot in
the bathroom and then turn out he was
taking a shower and I realized I don't
know some sort of sanctuary studio work
what's going on who's showering it by
variable shower at the NFL as well and
I'm fascinated by and I ask everyday to
the people that work near there does
anyone out mean who would house oiled
would one have to be to go and to go and
take a spritz in the middle of the day
well you know what it's like you're
sitting sitting in air conditioning and
an ergonomically designed chair and
eating free food at a cafeteria and then
at some point you got a hose off Brocius
salad you got to take a shower you know
one thing I have noticed in the 21st
century I'm all for equality in the
workplace and and everything else but
one thing that continues or in fact that
has emerged in the last few years is it
seems like there's a different standard
for women and men in this way women at
work in their cubicles where blankets
have you seen that move yeah what am I
like I'm chilly I'm gonna get a throw
it's very weird that women just sit
around in the cubicle with a blanket
draping them said they wilt up like
turn-of-the-century
cripples and wheelchairs you have no
feeling in your legs old man why do you
have the quilt over them I could put a
cigarette out on your kneecap you
wouldn't you wouldn't blink why why the
quilt right we're going into politically
now you're right but women women are
always I've gotten to this one with my
wife this is how you know women are
always cold because they know we're
always that argument turn the ceiling
fan on turn that I do this thing I get
hooked on the ceiling fan like it's
crack or methadone you know what I hit
the ceiling fan all summer long and then
it starts to change and it starts to get
cooler at night and before you know it
we're starting to head toward
Thanksgiving but I'm hooked on the siren
song of the ceiling fans and all night
and a certain point my wife because it's
45 degrees outside at this point goes
enough with the ceiling fan and I go
just double up on the comforter and put
the blankets over you who cares and
she'll go my foreheads cold
you you can take a letter opener and
stab it into my forehead I don't think I
was feeling I've never heard the
forehead temperature maybe she's being
passive-aggressive yeah I think so I
heard you just talking to eysan about
the the visits from the turkey and I do
find it fascinating the range in which
teams choose to cut players I think that
I would say what you want about Jerry
Jones he actually does the cutting
himself I think there's a nobility in
that that he that he's owning it and
then a lot of other teams have their
head coaches do it I love the what the
the hard knocks when the Cincinnati
Bengals did it they had an action a guy
who actually that was his gig was to go
and knock on your door but not just
knock on your door and it you know at
the end of practice or anything right he
would wake you up under the eyes of
night he would let's go uh hey uh need
your playbook oh go visit the gut look I
can't I get it you're gonna humiliate me
you can't even let me get a decent
night's sleep before you literally like
no it's important that we it's important
that we fire you while you have a boner
you must still have a boner you must
come in here with sweat pants and boner
and we will fire you like can't you let
me take a shower with the guy in the
hall here put some sweat pants on and
then fire me by the way with this weird
math I if you're talking to me like when
the Turk comes by like five 15 tells me
to get up walk into the man's office
with my boner get fired I could go back
to my room and fall asleep and then just
wake up the next day and show up to
practice or what no like had a dream I
got fired last night yeah that's the
George Costanza move right hey bring
your PlayBook bring your PlayBook to the
cup like what if you don't bring the
playbook and then you just hey got that
playbook yet though yeah I know I would
never have the play mountaineer by
D'Brickashaw you still waste like all of
the playbook I left that in my car
tomorrow okay yeah next thing you know
it's mid-october Oh Dave damn a Shack
and a film Network analysts here and
excited because uh checks a dear friend
an old friend I've known cheque for many
years ace it's a pleasure to see you
even more so now that your buddy your
heart is now fully assume now that your
football team is back in Los Angeles yes
you have the Rams
it's exciting except for I can't shake
the uncomfortable feeling that after 20
years that it's all it's all yeah who's
gonna come and everything and Case
Keenum that's what we have what we're
gonna get in week one it would appear
now yes keenum lament this often how is
it possible in a world of seven billion
people then we cannot find 32 human
beings to successfully play quarterback
in the NFL it is very weird yeah well
it's a tall order
speaking of tall McLovin is a dear
friends with case right oh I don't know
do you afraid that's what you say
commercial case is a good dude
yeah we are I was Pauly and I went down
to Irvine and not only his case a friend
of the show Sean Mannion is a super fan
of the Dan Patrick show was wearing a
stampatto t-shirt on Hard Knocks it said
flinch ball which is something we
invented and Jared Goff number one
overall pick also a DP show fans know
we're in with the Rams that's how we
pick who we root for in the league to
start and I start whether they watch our
show not about their abilities or if
they're a good quarterback he's I just
met Jared golf I went to the Coliseum
the other day and kibbutz with him and
boy he's a handsome devil yeah we're
trying to find Ryan Gosling at Brady
handsome Sanchez handsome yeah that's
not bad yeah that's yeah golf
immediately in the top five I think most
handsome NFL QB really I think Brady's
still number one but Garoppolo
oh yeah he's easy on the eyes Cam Newton
I mean listen I'm just by but I I
grapple oh yeah yeah that guy's hot
Garoppolo and in fact I've asked both
those guys Brady and Garoppolo who's
more handsome between the two of them
and they but they both were pretty
modest about it so I went to Gronk and
Gronk said Brady and I say and I'm with
him I think Brady is still the gold
standard well you take a look you know
one's dating Gisele Bundchen and then
everyone's dating a
hostess from hooters I think that's
really the deciding forget about Gronk
you know what I mean that's how you
that's the coin you decide you know who
you dating she started the Olympics like
she Rio
no they just marched her out into the
middle of the Coliseum just delight a
torch or something
a model someone who has nothing to do
with sports except for having sex with
everyone in sports which I guess makes
her an aficionado in a weird way like
maybe she's more into sports or sports
or more into her than anybody else but
she's a super she's a super model what
you have to do with the 11:00 tuning in
on these Olympics
I got it well somebody do you guys tell
me where you stand on this I tuned in
the other night and somebody asked me on
my show which sports would you cut from
the Olympics and I said that's true
we're getting a little fat and we're
getting into pellet guns and things like
that like we could trim it down a little
bit I said any sport where they do the
split-screen where they're like over
here let's see how international women's
basketball is doing over here and here's
junior soccer over here and they're
splitting the screen if you have to
split the screen down the middle meaning
there's not enough sport to take up a
whole TV set here that means you're on
the block call the Turk is when I say if
we're splitting the screen you've got to
call the Turk I mean we could yeah we
could definitely get rid of some dead
weight with that isn't it weird that we
live on if you feel like you know with
800 channels and whatever shouldn't we
be aware of all the sports out there and
yet every four years this exotic the the
one that I would most like to play is
team handball yeah I don't know the
rules exactly what's going on there
because they're running and then they
just periodically drop it for a second
and then get it back up and then they
throw I really want to play I think that
would be a good one to play drunk or
otherwise and the the one that
fascinates me the most in the in both
Olympics is the ski jump
because basketball as a for instance you
can go out and take 3,000 shots and
airball them all before you make one
that's
you can ramp up to it right what's the
equivalent of ski of that in ski the how
do you not break yourself the first 50
times or like the pole vault how do you
do that for the first time where I'm
gonna use this stick to fling me 20 feet
over well I mean at least you probably
start by putting the thing about the
high height of a bedpost there's
something and see if you can make it
over that but if the ski yeah it's true
and they didn't have foam pits back in
the day to practice on I like the four
man toboggan I think the four man sled
my feeling is I want either second or
third seat in the four manner because
the deal is the first guys got to do the
steering and the announcers are all up
his tuck it's like oh I clipped the wall
that's going to share precious just
because he's going down and I'm
basically a frozen banquette at 70 miles
an hour and God forbid he gets a little
wide on one of the turns that kicked you
up higher than Talladega as far as the
bank you know he caught it edge yeah
that's gonna slow the guy in the back
he's got a break you know so he's got
something to do the two middle guys as
far as I can tell they got a they got a
run as hard as it can for about seven
steps and then they jump into this
fiberglass coffin and attempt to perform
oral on themselves cuz that's all that's
all you do it's just run run run suck
suck suck and then then it's over it's
over that's and you didn't do it all
you're like huh where was I do they I
mean it is a fascinating thing if you
have the two-man bobsled yes what is the
need that then all know that he's in the
two men but he's not on the foot the
four-man bobsled yeah unnecessary I
never thought about dignity where's the
dignity in being the two and three yeah
then also how about the guy who
specializes in the three-man bobsled is
piss cuz it's like well we got this we
got the single guy right and then
there's the two right now that's right
coming no we go to four histories last
me by what about the try slide what
about
don't we hop to four we literally don't
need you to and three guys yes I'm still
going to the Olympics I'm you're not
taking this dream away from me and the
other one that they use the the icy
course thing for is the luge and I have
long speculated that I could make the US
luge team because there cannot be more
than three or four people in America who
have ever loosed ever I know just by
proclaiming you're willing to do it you
can make the luge team in America is
that is that the skeleton yeah that's
what you go down that face first
that's race first that's that serious I
would yeah and I would argue there many
people of skeleton but drunk and
unintentionally like I mean we're
camping it's cold outside I'm gonna take
a leak aw crap you know what I'm saying
I think people unintentionally but I
think they actually do it intentionally
and practice it all right how are we
doing on time two minutes all right we
got more time with video we're not gonna
be able to fill lace I run a tight ship
here like that I was listening earlier
and some of your questions so Jimmy
Kimmel's the funniest guy you know he
works it is in his blood is what is what
I say he he you know him well offstage
as well as I do it he doesn't change you
know what I mean like I'm guessing Sacha
Baron Cohen isn't farting on people's
heads when they pass out on the sofa be
probably serious and that's the
difference between Sasha Baron Cohen and
Jimmy Kimmel Lange is farting on your
head that's what I'm that's what I'm
saying like I'm saying a Jimmy there's
no you know I didn't you wouldn't get
the feeling like they keep a guy like
Bob Hope or Letterman or guys like that
we're super you know non-stop joke
machines off the air
Jimmy is Jimmy's why I agree I don't
mean Jimmy's Jimmy ho no Carola is also
you know I think everybody can confirm
will is pretty much the same guy on the
air as he is off but Corolla also you
may not know
puts everybody who he meets through a
probationary period I experienced this a
number of years ago where literally we
sat well I was one of four people
watching NFL football for a Sunday and
he literally over seven hours did not
even look in my direction imagine being
in a room a small room and being one of
four people and he acknowledges every
one of the other two guys but does not
even address anything in your direction
why did you do that again ace I have to
vet hmm understand if you ever get to my
position David I just heard how that
sounded but if hear to the big desk
Kibby cable over there you'll realize
that a man of my importance cannot take
time to have a lot of johnny-come-lately
pass through their life you have to be
fully vetted good news is you pass the
test bad news is it's been seven years
and it's time to re-up the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience